what's up everybody welcome back to the
rumor roundup and i'm not rob rob is
actually out this weekend with his
fiance mariah it's her birthday weekend
so everybody say happy birthday to
mariah down in the comments below and
rob was like tc i need you to cover dc
fandom for me and i was like rob
everybody hates the new guy everybody
hates the new face everybody hates
anyone who's not you on this channel and
i was like fine okay i'll jump in front
of the firing squad and i'll do my best
so today we're gonna go over the most
hyped announcements to come out of dc
fandom so dc phantom started out with a
bang or should i say a bolt we finally
got to see the black adam teaser a movie
14 years in the making guys the rock has
been clamoring to play the role of black
adam for 14 years put that into
perspective before the mcu even started
but today as a rock would say finally
black adam has come to
the movie screens and we finally got to
see our first glimpse at dwayne
johnson's black adam and he looks super
cool guys with the with the cloak and
the electricity i mean this thing really
made him seem like a real badass and i i
love this trailer i thought it did
exactly what it needed to you know as
soon as shazam has said black adam shows
up he uses the most electrifying move in
black atom entertainment and
disintegrates that guy into dust then
he's fired upon by all the machine guns
stops a bullet in midair which really
really cool and at the end levitates
like a god but in the end um i thought
this teaser did exactly what it was
supposed to do it gave us a little tease
we didn't really get to see fully see
the rock because he was kind of covered
up most of the time
but uh you really get a sense that the
shift in power is truly about to change
in the dc eu all right so the next bit
of news was the aquaman the lost kingdom
footage where they showed a lot of
behind the scenes stuff they showed you
know black manta ocean master james wan
doing his thing back there and he showed
amber herds mira which i was like really
they showed her because she's gonna be
the source of a lot of controversy when
this film actually hits because of all
her you know antics with uh johnny depp
and what's going on between them but i'm
curious to see you know what type of
backlash it gets just because she's
still in the movie but anyway this movie
looks insane it looks
like in a movie experience a la like
avatar experience this looks like a
freaking fun movie that's going to take
you to a bunch of exotic places to sing
a bunch of exotic creatures
and
that's what this movie kind of feels to
me it feels like an experience more than
an actual like good written script of a
movie but we don't know
i'm just going off of the first movie
the first aquaman which i thought was
dumb fun basically got to see jason
momoa in his black suit which of course
you guys know or you guys don't know but
i think that the golden armor from the
first aquaman is like top three comic
accurate suits of all time in movies so
anything after that was gonna be a
downgrade in my opinion but anyway
uh i thought everything shown here just
kind of gave you a glimpse at what this
next aquaman movie is gonna be about and
they're going for it man they're going
for treasure planet they're going for
atlantis
lost city of atlantis whatever these
disney experiences this movie is going
to be an experience you'll never forget
all right so the next thing of note that
i want to talk about is the flash teaser
because dc is sitting in the background
like watching marvel and watching
spider-man no way home watching doctor
strange multiverse of madness about to
come out and they're like hey
we have a multiverse too hey don't
forget about us we're doing the flash
movie guys with this whole multiverse
and flash running through multiverses
yeah do you see you better hurry up
because marvel is about to corner the
market on multiverses
um but anyway the flash teaser came out
and a lot of people are iffy about this
movie because it's supposed to be
rewriting a lot of the old dceu zack
snyder stuff and gonna make like a a new
timeline going forward but in this
teaser this teaser
got me intrigued like i think this movie
is going to be a mess i'm not going to
lie and lie to you guys here i think
it's going to be a mess if they don't do
it right i think it's going to confuse
the um casual viewers
but this watching this teaser trailer
really got me super hyped because and
more intrigued because we got to see
michael keaton's batman he's narrating
this whole thing he's talking to barry
and barry's
he shows up in that injustice god's
among us looking suit and i was like oh
my god this this suit is already 10
times better than the zack snyder dc eu
suit that's taped up and stuff like that
like this suit is freaking injustice
suit although i did see a lot of people
making fun of the cowl online and how it
doesn't really fit his face right i
thought it was i don't know i need a
better look at it but to me it looked
okay but um yeah so he's talking to
barry in this trailer and telling him
you know why are you sticking around
here you know you can
you can go wherever you want and uh so
we see the lead up and then you know we
get the money shot at the end where you
can see the cow he kind of walks forward
and you immediately know like this guy
can't turn his head left or right it has
to be michael keaton right
and uh yeah so there's a shot there of
like supergirl and i think it's an
alternate version of barry like
alongside him and he's asking him are
you in and then of course
you guys could have shown us the
batmobile you didn't like we know
michael keaton's in this movie why did
you not just
unveil the tarp at the end and just show
us the batmobile but anyway this movie
is super interesting to me
because
it's going to rewrite the dcu moving
forward they can do anything they want
they can retcon anything they want
and uh
this is going to be freaking insane with
the amount of cameos they can have in
this ben affleck slated to be in this
movie michael keaton's batman like how
they get interact how's that interaction
gonna be this movie is if it's anything
it's intriguing for even anyone who's
like off the dcu at this point they're
like i'm done snyder's not here whatever
uh this movie could potentially if it's
great bring those people back in so uh
those are just my thoughts on the
trailer let me know what you guys
thought do you guys think that this
movie is going to set a good path moving
forward for the dcu or do you think it's
just going to be a jumbled mess and just
confuse everybody even more so for all
you gamers out there we did get two
video game trailers in this dc fandom
the first one being suicide squad kill
the justice league and the second one
being gotham knights in the suicide kill
the justice league i mean they're mostly
been cinematic trailers there haven't
been a lot of gameplay trailers but
you really get a sense of you know the
suicide squad going against you know
infected members of the justice league
you had evil superman there doing his
thing he had evil flash in this trailer
and um i mean the whole concept of the
suicide squad going against like an
infected justice league is super cool
the only thing i'm kind of iffy about is
like power levels like a harley quinn's
gonna hogans and evil flash i don't
think so i don't know how they're gonna
be able to balance that out
uh or make it part of the storyline and
the second trailer we got was for gotham
knights and that trailer was super eerie
whenever you have the court of owls i
love the quarterbacks the whole
aesthetic the whole eerie vibe the whole
eerie aura about it and this this this
video games like story looks like it's
gonna be super freaking scary and creepy
and i'm just into anything creepy like
that i need to play as nightwing batgirl
basically the bat family and the makers
of this game were of course the
the people who made the arkham origins
game and so i know a lot of people are
excited for this bat family uh gotham
knights game but um those are the two
trailers we got let me know which game
you're more looking forward to playing
down in the comments down below so
before we get to the main event and you
guys know what the main event is the
batman trailer we have to talk about
something that i was like it got me
super hyped almost like more hype than
the batman trailer itself guys batman
caped crusader i
am probably the biggest batman the
animated series fan i know everyone says
that but i binge watched that series so
many times i
love the art noir style of batman the
animated series it is to me the
definitive batman the most batman batman
we will ever get i love bruce tim i love
pauldini i love everything they did with
that show and even moving on to like
justice league and limited and justice
league and you know batman superman
crossovers i am so in love with the dcau
that this announcement of batman caped
crusader where bruce tim's gonna team up
with uh jj abrams he's gonna team up
with matt reeves on
basically a reincarnated version
eight i believe bruce timm said it is a
more batman the animated series
of batman animated series which oh my
god
like this is gonna be freaking amazing
we're gonna get brought back to our
freaking childhood watching this new
show i for one cannot wait for this and
this i think i popped the loudest when i
was watching dc fandom for this
announcement i was like they're doing it
they're actually doing it okay guys it's
main event time the batman trailer this
is what everybody was waiting for i was
in the dc fandom chat live chat and i
was like when's batman where's batman i
don't care about anything else where's
batman well we finally got it we got the
batman trailer number two and uh it
didn't disappoint this trailer
along with like trailer number one is
freaking amazing you have you know a
shot at the beginning that reminds me of
that famous painting nighthawks i forgot
the artist
who has like that famous diner painting
but it's just so cinematic you see that
first shot
and of course it's the riddler with the
little question mark in the coffee
and um just this whole trailer is
freaking epic you got colin farrell
doing
a fantastic penguin when you never
thought colin farrell would be a
fantastic penguin
you have catwoman in there doing her
thing you have robin robert pattinson
you know going toe-to-toe with the
riddler basically and before this even
started this was a batman he said this
batman doesn't have control yet this
batman works you know but very much off
of emotions and he can't really control
his emotions yet which is very
interesting to me because you guys know
i think the batman animated series bama
is the definitive batman and
batman to me in his prime has control
over his emotions he's able to
objectively see something and he won't
let his emotions overtake him
there's only rare instances where he
does kind of snap and kind of go over
the edge
but in this robert pattinson's uh
batman he's he doesn't have that control
yet so you can see in this trailer like
he's you know wailing on people and he's
like
shouting at religious can't control his
emotions so i think that's a very
interesting
kind of new twist that they're gonna
have here with this batman but the
trailer itself guys i mean it is so
beautifully shot you have this crime
thriller that
it's something new it's it's a new take
on batman that i don't think we've ever
gotten um i would say it's akin to
christopher nolan's you know gritty
style except this is a bit different
this is straight up crime drama um it's
coming of age for robert baton since
batman it's year one basically so
but yeah some highlights in the trailer
you have
robert pattinson
kind of speaking directly with the
riddler and kind of going off and
you know what have you done a lot a lot
of people said they couldn't hear what
he says there but he says what have you
done
um then you have that epic finale with
the car crash and you see batman's
batmobile fly through the fire with
batman walking up slowly to the same
song that they use in the first trailer
but um it's still very effective and uh
man i cannot wait for this movie i don't
need to see any more trailers anymore
just give me the movie i don't want to
see any more trailers i'm good i'm sold
you have my
10 or whatever it is to go to the
theater i am all in for this movie but
thank you guys so much for letting me
fill in for rob if you guys want to
follow me you can follow me on twitter
at tc does comics what did you guys
think about dc phantom did you love it
did you hate it did you like last year's
better let me know down in the comments
down below and peace out guys